this is tadiq Persian crispy rice
[Music]
over it took me so long to finally
attempt taddy but it's so much easier
than I thought it would be what gives it
the crunch is a special two-part cooking
process start off by rinsing your
basmati rice and let it soak for an hour
the par cook the rice pull off the heat
and rinse it off in a strainer with cold
water now this is where we take it to
the next level to the pot you cook the
rice in add half a cup each of oil and
water I optionally added some saffron
water and turmeric for extra color and
flavor add the rice back giving it a pat
for optimal pan contact then make a
bunch of holes halfway to let steam
Escape Now cover cook over High just
until the rice begins to steam turn down
to low and cook for 45 more minutes
foreign
[Music]